bill's coach sean mcdermott met with
reporters on tuesday to look back on the
season it was and among other things he
was asked about the decision not to go
for a touchdown but to go for a field
goal right before half time when facing
a chiefs team that field goals will not
beat here's mcdermott
the one before half really felt like uh
you know morale was a big piece of that
you know they had momentum
uh they were getting the ball after half
as well vic and felt like we needed to
come away with points
at that one because even though
sometimes analytics may say one thing
whether it said it or not on our chart
i think there's a human element to the
game at the end of the day and i felt
like we needed to come away with points
as i look at those guys in the locker
room and say hey
we got something to show for for that
drive we put together at the end of the
half and i thought that was important
because it was getting awfully awfully
tough tough sledding there for a little
bit
i understand what coach mcdermott's
saying there but again the human element
is you're facing the chiefs and field
goals will not beat the chiefs you have
to match
touchdown with touchdown especially as
you feel like the game is beginning to
get out of your grasp you know we see
upsets in the playoffs
turn on
that moment that makes us say uh-oh like
the scottie miller touchdown right
when you're going into a place where you
are expected to lose in the postseason
chris i think you need to have in your
bag of tricks
an uh-oh moment you need to have
something ready to go that's going to
flip things your way otherwise you're
just not going to win the game well yes
you know and they've had that all year i
mean we've talked about it they've had
trick plays anything you want like that
we talked about this on monday
i kind of said exactly what sean
mcdermott did right there i didn't have
as much of a problem with the one before
the half i did not because if you go in
21 down 21 9 and they're going wait
kansas city's going to get the ball
morale could be an issue to where the
team goes damn we're screwed we're out
of this there so there is a little logic
in human psychology there just at least
in my experience being in football to
where you know you go in you go okay we
got some points yeah we're we're down
nine right we can still salvage this we
like this even you know
no matter what happens here there there
is something to that and also we got to
remember their offense hadn't done jack
diddley squat until that drive they had
a hard time doing anything so i think
there was something there too where he's
going man one play they've had the best
of us really the whole half
let me just kick a feel a little go away
with that you you know me and i think
you're more of this too
my issue is the next field goal and now
it's 24 to 12 and now you go wait it's
the third quarter and you're not going
to stop them it's apparent we got to
start being aggressive and that's where
uh you know i disagree but he addressed
that too and he understands that as well
it sounds like he said he's kicking
yourself a little bit at the end of the
day let's just be aggressive there as it
relates to the second second one yeah
not the first one but but again and this
is something i don't know how much of
this stuff you actively plan for as a
coach during the season this is where
experience in the postseason becomes
very helpful but
my experience of watching it and
studying it for 40 plus years is if
you're gonna score the upset on the road
in a playoff game you have to craft
those moments you have to engineer
momentum in your favor you have to be
ready to do something gutsy something
maybe unexpected but something different
from the normal formula that you would
apply in a regular season game because
in a regular season game you got next
week
in a postseason game
you don't remember the andy reid quote
after going forward on fourth and one
against the browns trying to hold the
lead there is no tomorrow if you're the
underdog you need to take that that
mentality even more to heart there is no
tomorrow you're david he's goliath and
you better have a pretty good stone in
your slingshot and be ready to aim at
chris yeah no i listen i think they're
very aware of that you know that's why
they always had those type of plays
throughout the year i just think that
was a tough moment right there and they
were clearly over matched as a football
team at the end of the day
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports